fueron usados por primera vez en síria
para parar una ofensiva del régimen de
bashar al-assad y su aliado vladimir
putin después turquía también los usó en
libia donde consiguió forzar un alto al
fuego que aún sigue vigente después en
octubre desde 2000 mismo 2020 fueron
usados por azerbaiyán para derrotar a
armenia en su conflicto en el nagorno
karabaj estamos hablando de los drones
bayraktar propiedad de una empresa
privada y privada cuyo propietario es ni
más ni menos que el número de reyes
tayip erdogán estos drones o aviones no
tripulados se especializan por ser
aparte de muy baratos muy poderosos para
derrotar y poder despistar a los defensa
a los sistemas de defensa entera del
enemigo que no pueden detectarlos por
ser tan pequeños y volar tan alto en el
cielo sin embargo no se sabía si estos
drones que consiguieron derrotar a los
sistemas antiaéreos de siria los
rebeldes libios y armenia serían capaces
de derrotar y de ser también tan
efectivos ante un rival con unos
sistemas tecnológicos mucho más
avanzados ucrania compró en 2021 varias
decenas de estaciones y los zonas los
están usando en este mismo conflicto
después de la invasión de las tropas
rusas comandados por vladimir putin y
esto
ser muy efectivo ante unos sistemas anti
aéreos rusos que no pueden hacerles
frente y unas columnas que están siendo
atacadas constantemente por estos drones
según están mostrando varios vídeos
publicados por el ministerio de defensa
de ucrania y la embajada o craneana en
turquía turquía sin embargo tiene miedo
de que este uso de estos drones pueda
enemistarla con rusia con cuyo a
cuyas relaciones son muy importantes
para turquía tanto en materia económica
como en siria donde si rusia que se se
podría forzar una nueva ola refugiados y
una nueva un nuevo recalentamiento de un
conflicto que turquía no puede
permitirse ni no quiere permitir en un
futuro